Від нової Верховної Ради були великі очікування після Майдану.
Порівняно з попереднім складом, парламент оновився більш, ніж наполовину.
Депутати обіцяли працювати "по-новому".
Та чи виконуються обіцянки?
За три роки у Верховній Раді зареєстрували понад
10 тисяч законопроектів і це -
рекорд в історії українського парламенту.
Майже всі ці законопроекти ініціювали не урядовці,
а саме народні обранці.
Втім, законами з цієї купи паперів стали лише
близько 12 відсотків законопроектів,
відзначають у Комітеті виборців України.
Решта - законодавчий спам, який ніколи не стане законом.
Експерти звертають увагу на низьку якість документів.
Законопроекти масово реєструються фактично
без перспективи бути прийнятими
і використовуються політиками для популізму.
При цьому найголовніші обіцянки досі так і не були виконані,
зокрема скасувати депутатську недоторканість,
обирати парламент за відкритими списками
та ліквідувати місцеві держадміністрації.
Інший показовий тренд нинішнього складу Верховної Ради -
депутати свідомо ігнорують голосування,
хоча начебто присутні у залі.
Ось статистика на прикладі голів фракцій,
які потенційно можуть змагатися за президентське крісло на наступних виборах.
Лідер радикалів Олег Ляшко
за даними письмової реєстрації
відвідав 84 відсотки пленарних засідань,
але пропустив майже половину голосувань,
порахували у Комітеті виборців України.
Лідерка "Батьківщини" відвідала 80 відсотків пленарних засідань.
При цьому пропустила три чверті усіх голосувань.
А лідер "Опозиційного блоку" Юрій Бойко
письмово зареєстрований аж під час 94 відсотків пленарних засідань,
але брав участь лише у 3 відсотках голосувань!
На практиці це означає, що ці та інші депутати реєструються,
але потім зникають з парламентської зали.
У парламентарів залишається менше двох років, аби виконати свої обіцянки
і довести, що Верховна Рада восьмого скликання
оновилася не лише за іменами,
але й за відповідальним підходом до роботи.